Bitte schön.
Oh, entschuldigung Sie.
Okay, schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Köklka. Ich bin der Diensthabender aus der Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Patientingespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, gerne, Doktor. Bitte schön.
Vielen Dank. Kurzumablauf, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen. Dann können wir Ihre aktuelle Becherung übergehen.
Wenn Sie jetzt nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, melden Sie sich bitte bei mir.
Mein Name ist Heiner Geisler.
Geisler, Heiner mit A-Umlaut oder EI?
EI, Heiner, HEI.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Geiger?
Ich bin jetzt 65 Jahre alt geworden.
Wann gehen Sie aus ins Geburten, können Sie mir sagen?
4. Februar 1958.
Sie haben gesagt, 4. Februar 1958.
Vielen Dank. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie, Herr Geiger?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,85 m.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen abgenommen, aber es gibt ungefähr 70 kg.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen in der letzten Zeit?
Im letzten halben Jahr waren es doch fast 9 bis 10 kg. Ich hatte 79,80 kg gehabt.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen abgenommen.
Unwielkürliche oder ungewollte Abgelöhnung?
Ich habe auch meine Ernährung umgestellt. Ich wollte schon abnehmen.
Aber es ist ein bisschen über das Zähne hinaus geschossen.
Sie haben gesagt, in der Halb-Sechs-Monat sind es 10 kg, oder?
So ungefähr, ja.
Was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann ich Sie tun, Herr Geiger?
Das Problem ist, ich habe heute Morgen im Spiegel gemerkt, dass meine Augen gelb sind.
Dann hat meine Mitarbeiterin auch gesagt, ich wäre auf der Haut gelb.
Deswegen bin ich zu ihnen gekommen, mit dem Kaganhaus.
Ich verstehe Sie. Haben Sie eine andere Schwerde, wie z. B. ob Schmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen?
Das erste Mal diese gebeliche Farbe?
Das erste Mal. Ich habe noch nie vorher eine Gelbsucht gehabt.
Ich habe keine Beschwerden.
Vor drei, vier Wochen hatte ich eine Thrombose im Bein.
Das war auch an der Flugreise.
Da war ich verreist.
Auf dem Rückflug hatte ich Beschwerden im Bein.
Ich habe Schmerzen und Schmerzen, wo ich beim Haus saß.
Da hat ich eine Thrombose festgestellt.
Ich verstehe Sie. Haben Sie dagegen etwas Blutverdünne?
Ja, ich habe mir immer Spritzen aufgeschrieben, wie ich mir selbst setze.
Jeden Tag mache ich eine Spritze.
Ja, okay. Jeden Tag Blutverdünne.
Okay, seit heute Morgen?
Ja, ich möchte über die gestern sprechen, gestern Abend zum Beispiel.
Ich habe mir etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt,
mit dem Essen oder etwas anderes Bauchschmerzen vollgefühlt.
Etwas anderes Gefühl in den Bauch.
Kann ich nicht sagen, Doktor? Nein.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasselassen oder Stuhlrank
oder ungewöhnliches bemerkt, wie zum Beispiel dunklen Urin oder Herrlich?
Das ist mir schon oft, nachdem ich das gemerkt habe.
Ich kann nicht sagen, dass der Urin dunkler ist als sonst.
Der Stuhl ist auch von der Farbe anders.
Haben Sie recht, ja.
Aber das habe ich heute erst gemerkt,
nachdem ich die Gelbverdung im Auge von den Hautgespungen gemerkt habe.
Wie sieht die Stuhl aus?
Können Sie etwas genauer, etwas besserer sagen?
Ist das Blut in Stuhl?
Blut ist nicht dabei, nein.
Es ist hell und teilweise auch ein bisschen gräulich gewesen.
Aber nicht die normale Stuhlfarbe, die ich kenne.
Das ist bestätig.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Das ist erst einmal.
Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Lebensgewandheiten fragen.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Reiger?
Ja, ich rauche ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie pro Tag?
Also das sind sicherlich 20 Zigaretten, die ich pro Tag rauche.
Das ist sehr schön.
Ich empfehle Ihnen ein bisschen zu reduzieren.
Wenn Sie möchten, ich empfehle Ihnen auch eine Beratung zu stellen.
Sie sind auch in unserer Klinikum.
Jetzt rennt noch mal darüber sprechen gerne.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Wie viele Jahre lang haben Sie gebaut?
Ich habe es für mich auch mal aufgehört, pausiert.
Aber letztlich, seit 18 Lebensjahr,
mehr als 50 Jahre, ich würde sagen.
Ja, 40 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Also Glaswein zum Essen abends ist dabei.
Vielleicht dann machen wir mal auch ein paar Bier mit Kollegen.
Aber nicht mehr.
Aber Sie kontakt mit der Brugel?
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nein, ich nehme keine Brugel.
Dankeschön.
Ich würde gerne ein bisschen eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Heute Morgen haben Ihre Kollegen bemerkt,
dass Sie eine gelbische Papierin in Ihrem Augen bemerkt.
Das habe ich selbst gemerkt.
Die Kollegen haben gemerkt, dass auf meine Haut Geld ist.
Okay.
Haben Sie jücken als sonst mehr als sonst?
Kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen.
Ne, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben dunkler Uwein und heller Stuhl.
Als sonst, haben Sie Übelkeit, mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein, habe ich jetzt keine Probleme gehabt.
Bisher.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Als sonst in der letzten Zeit haben Sie Schlauchprobleme?
Also ich habe schon immer Durchschlauchstörungen,
aber das ist jetzt seit vielen, vielen Jahren so.
Ist nichts Neues.
Ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Nacht Schweiß?
Sind Ihnen aufgefallen?
Ich habe mich nicht gemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie Fieber gemessen oder etwas Stilfrost gehabt?
Stilfrost habe ich nicht gehabt, Fieber habe ich nicht gemessen,
aber ich habe mich jetzt auch nicht heiß angeführt.
Ich kann nicht verneinen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein in der letzten Zeit
Abgeschlagenheiten, Müdigkeit?
Haben Sie solche Beschwerden in der letzten Zeit
etwas Schwierigkeiten beim täglichen Aufgaben zu erledigen?
Also ich habe schon gemerkt, dass ich nicht mehr so fit bin wie früher.
Also ich meine, das Alter ist auch nicht mehr so wie früher.
Es ist natürlich jetzt fortgeschritten.
Also eine gewisse körperlichen Abbau kann ich in den letzten Jahren schon feststellen.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie eine andere Althose oder etwas anderes mit dem Jahr
vielleicht erkrankt haben.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, akustisch.
Leiden Sie an Vorerkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Althose.
Ja, Althose nicht, aber Bluthochdruck ist bekannt bei mir.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Ja, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Und seit wann haben Sie diese?
Bluthochdruck habe ich so ungefähr seit 10, 15 Jahren.
Ist das bekannt bei mir?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Nehmen Sie dagegen welche Medikamente?
Ja, da habe ich verschiedene Medikamente.
Ich habe auch einige Herzmedikamente, weil ich auch mit dem Herzenmal-Problem hatte.
Also ich habe einen solchen Art Herzinfarkt vorstuf,
weil ich einen Herzinfarkt gehabt habe vor 5, 6 Jahren.
Und da nehme ich auch ein paar Medikamente ein.
Also gegen Bluthoch nehme ich Walzacor ein.
Walzacor, ja.
Und Amnodipin.
Und dann habe ich halt noch, weil ich damals auch bei dem Vorstuf
von einem Herzinfarkt auch Stands bekommen habe.
Ja, ich will auch Ausfringer.
ASS ein, ASS, also 100 Medikam.
Und habe noch Bisoprol bekommen, also ein Beta-Blocker.
Sie haben drei Medikamente gegen diese Bluthochdruck.
Bekannten Sie mir diese Dosierungen nehmen?
Welche Dosierungen haben die alle Medikamente?
Und wie in Offenen nehmen Sie das?
Also Walzacor sind 16 Medikamente,
nehme ich einmal pro Tag.
Amnodipin nehme ich abends 5 Medikamente.
Und das Bisoprol, das sind 2,5 Medikamente am morgens
abends eine Tablette.
Und dann habe ich noch den Cholesterinsenkern
bekommen, das Atorvastatin, 20, nämlich abends ein.
Und wenn wir schon bei den Medikamenten sind,
ich spritze halt wegen der Thromboose jeden Tag.
Ja, blüten.
Sie haben gleich über diese Herzkrankheit und Herzinfarkt gesprochen.
Können Sie mir etwas genauer beschreiben, vor fünf Jahren,
Sie haben eine Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Also eine Vorstufe war das, habe ich mir gesagt,
eine Vorstufe war.
Okay.
Außer diese Blutfurchtung haben Sie,
ich glaube, diese Blutfettwerte, Blutfettstorungen,
als Vorerkrankungen Sie haben gewonnen.
Nein, das haben Sie mir nach dem Herzinfarkt aufgeschrieben,
dass das Cholesterins gesenkt wird
und das für die Herzkranzgefäße günstig wäre.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind bei Ihnen allergienbecher,
entschuldigen Sie, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Greitwer?
Oh, schon lange her, da war ich jung,
hatte eine Blinddarm-Operation, habe ich gehabt
und hatte mal so eine Züste gehabt,
die in der Haut, das ist auch schon lange her,
ich weiß nicht, was es war, es war vor 40 Jahren.
Sie haben gesagt, ich bin halt wirklich nicht verstanden,
ich bin ja in der Haut, war mal entfernt worden, ja, so.
Aber schon lange her, ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr,
was damals das Problem war, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannt, Herr Greitwer?
Keine Bekannt, ich habe keine Allergie.
Gegen Medikamente geht Ihnen eine Stoffe?
Nein, ist nichts bekannt, nein.
Okay, vielen nein.
Ja, haben Sie, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, die sind beide verstorben.
Nein, ich bin mir leid, woan gestorben Sie?
Können Sie mir sagen?
Also meine Mutter ist an ein Brustkreis verstorben
und meine Falle hat auch Grebs, hat ein Dickdammkrebs,
ist auch daran verstorben.
Ich verstehe Sie, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Nein, ich glaube so, Sie sind Rentner, so seid...
Nein, ich arbeite noch.
Ich bin selbstständig, deswegen arbeite ich noch, ja.
Welchen Beruf haben Sie jetzt?
Ich bin Rechtsanwalt.
Okay, sind Sie percheiratet, Herr Greitwer?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, ja, sind erwachsen.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Am Anfang möchte ich versuchen,
ein bisschen Zusammenfassung zu machen,
aber jetzt kann ich diese Zusammenfassung machen.
Heute Morgen, Sie haben eine gelbliche Papierandung
in der Augen bemerkt.
Und auch Ihr Kollegen haben Sie
in Gesicht und Haut diese Papierandung bemerkt.
Ja, vor drei oder vier Wochen vorher
haben Sie eine Trombose bei der Beine gehabt.
Und...
Linkes Bein nur?
Rechter Bein, ja.
Linkes Bein, deswegen nehmen Sie
täglich eine Blutverdünne Spritze.
Richtig.
Und Sie haben sowohl dunkle Urin
als auch dunkle Stuhl bemerkt.
Herr Hellerstuhl.
Herr Hellerstuhl, das ist mein Schulte.
Okay, bemerkt.
Und ich glaube, das ist alles.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder möchten Sie mich korrektieren?
Nein, das waren die wichtigsten Beschwerden,
die Sie richtigerweise zusammengefasst haben, ja Herr Doktor.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchte ich Sie über meine weitere Procedere berichten?
In der Linie werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Von Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Dann einen Bauch Ultraschall,
so wie einen Röntgen Bauch durchschrücken.
Dann einen gegebenen Preis
von Ihnen einen Urin-Probe bekommen.
Okay, ja.
Dann können Sie diese Stuhl-Probe
um Stuhldiagnostik festziehen.
Dann gegebenenfalls werde ich Sie
einen Computer-Tomographie durchfügen.
Das sind Röntgenstrahlen, dann, ja?
Ja, CT-Befunde gibt es nicht so hoch,
wie Flug nach New York oder so.
Dann werden alle wofür die Stuhl-Tomographie durchfügen.
Kann man die Alternative nicht auch in den MRT machen?
Ich habe von allen Kollegen gehört, die machen MRT statt CT.
Ja, wenn wir diese andere wesentliche Erkrankung ausschließen,
können wir diese MRT und auch eine RSR,
das ist das letzte, das wir auf die Partien zu akklingen,
eine andere Unterjungsmethode durchfügen.
Also statt dieser CT, das man MRT macht, vielleicht?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich würde mich darum bitten,
weil ich bin auch privat versichert,
so kostensollen keine Probleme darstellen.
Ich kann es nicht.
Ich werde alle diese erledigen.
Ja, Sie sind rechthandmalten.
Ich glaube, Sie haben eine Krankenkasteversicherung.
Ja, ich bin privat versichert.
Okay, kein Problem.
Dann, wenn alle Befünder vorliegen,
kommen ich zu Ihnen und zu Ihnen.
Was denken Sie hier, Doktor,
dass die Ursache dafür sein kann?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen...
Wir haben schon die Erfahrung mit solchen Problemen.
Ja, es ist etwas genau zu sagen, es ist ein bisschen früh,
aber ich habe verdacht,
auch eine Ankreasprobleme, Bauchsprachlerüse,
Probleme und auch könnte es ein Krebserkrank,
weil sie haben eine Familie,
weil Mutter und Vater haben,
Krebserkrankungen gelitten.
Es könnte sein, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher,
Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Und jetzt nachdem alle Befünder,
wie können Sie sprechen?
Bauchsprachlösenkrebs ist ganz schlecht.
Ich kenne das von anderen Kollegen,
das kann man nicht behandeln.
Ja, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Wir haben sehr viele Untersuchungen
und Therapiemethode,
aber wenn wir festgestellt sind,
können wir diese Medikamente, Chemotherapie
oder andere Therapie fangen.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorge,
das ist ein Verdacht Noah,
innerhalb 2 oder 3 Spiele können wir das genauer sprechen.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber ich habe da schon jetzt...
Was böserlich ist, ein Bauchsprachlöse,
da habe ich ganz schlimme Sachen gehört.
Ich habe auch Kollegen am Bauchsprachlösenkrebs verloren.
Ja, meine Schmerz.
Schmerz hilft dann nichts bei denen.
Denken Sie bitte nicht, die Schlimmste.
Es könnte sein, ich andere verursachen können,
wie zum Beispiel eine Gallenblase Entschuldung.
Vielleicht könnte es sein Gallenblase...
Okay, könnte ich da nicht schmerzen?
Oder was meinen Sie?
Sie haben keinen Schmerzen.
Ja, passt das dazu.
Also ich dachte auch immer, Krebs macht Schmerzen, oder?
Könnte sein, dass es doch kein Krebs ist,
oder ob es nicht so ist, oder ob es nicht so ist.
Ich habe diese Verdacht, weil Sie haben Gewicht,
Sie haben von 6 Monaten,
circa 10 kg von Gewichts angewohnt.
Ich habe auch anders gegessen,
ich habe meine Ernährung umgestellt, vielleicht liegt es noch daran.
Sie haben gesagt, das ist ungewohnt.
Ja, also ich habe abgenommen,
weil ich das Ziel hinausgeschlossen habe, ich habe gesagt,
ich habe meine Ernährung umgestellt.
Ich habe auch gesagt, dass es vielleicht doch nicht Krebs ist.
Was meinen Sie?
Es könnte sein, ich werde nicht diese Entscheidungen selbst trocken.
Wir sind in Thims,
jetzt ich spreche mit meinem Chefarzt.
Okay, okay.
Ich muss halt Sachen regeln, wenn es Krebs ist,
dann ich habe eine Kanzlei, die muss ich weiterführen
und ich muss das schon wissen.
Ich habe eine finanzielle Verpflichtung,
ich muss das klären.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen,
aber das ist ein bisschen früh, um diese Stoffe zu sprechen.
Wenn mir diese Jagdmusur festgestellt wird, können wir darüber sprechen.
Okay, und machen Sie bitte alles, was möglich ist,
weil Geld spielt keine Rolle bei mir.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Ich mache etwas, bestes mein.
Danke, vielen Dank.
Guten Tag.
Geißler, ich spiele sofort in Privatzima.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Das ist nicht von Ihnen.
Danke schön für die Betreuung.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe Kollegen oder Kollegen, die andere fragen.
Ich habe eine Verpflichtung, die ich mit der Stoffe verwendet habe.
Ja, ich weiß, dass Sie es nicht tun.
Ja, bitte.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich muss alles durch die Stoffe...
Ein Bettzimmer, Chef als Behandlung.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Was hätten Sie noch fragen können?
Nach Schweiß, schon gefragt.
Hat gefragt, kein Nach Schweiß.
Der Patin hat Trombose gehabt nach der Flugreise.
Ja.
Wo war er? Welches Land?
Welches Land habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber es könnte sein ein bisschen nach Fernweg,
weil es ein Trombose gibt.
Ja, ja.
Welches Land hat die Ansteckung?
Gelbstucht.
Welche Krankheit macht Gelbstucht?
Ja, das passt.
Das hätte ich gefragt.
Ich platz.
Wenn es zum Beispiel,
keine Ahnung,
Dänemark oder Schweden ist,
dann muss man nach sexuell übertragenden Krankheiten noch mehr.
Also auch Fragen nach sexual Verhalten.
Kann man ruhig stellen bei solchen Männern.
Auch wenn sie geschieden sind und so weiter.
Und auch nach Sachen, die dort gegessen haben.
Zum Teil, zum Beispiel,
keine Ahnung, ganz ungekochte Sachen.
Streetfood oder was essen.
Da kann man natürlich auch über das A-Bahn.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Also Reisendammnäße kann man noch mal fragen.
Wer vielleicht in dem Samstag nicht verkehrt,
aber ihre Verdachtdiagnose war schon richtig.
Was gibt es noch für Fragen?
Hat er gefragt, Fieber war nicht.
Aber sonst war, glaube ich,
schon ein bisschen zu viel.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Aber sonst war, glaube ich,
Stuhlverhalten, gewichtsverlust,
Schmerzen hat er verneint.
Und sonst war, glaube ich,
die wichtigste, die es gefragt worden ist, glaube ich.
Ja, ich denke, die wichtigste Ahnung, die Frage ist gestärkt.
Können wir als Herzgechüpfchen anfangen?
Gerne.
Bitteschön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Chefarzt, weil jetzt Privatpatient ist jetzt.
Guten Abend, Herr Chefarzt.
Ich habe gleich einen neuen Patiente gesehen.
Patiente gesehen und würde gerne Sie ihm vorstellen.
Haben Sie seit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Herr Reiner Geistler
ist 65-jährige Patient.
Er ist 1,85 m groß und 70 kg schwer.
Herr Geister hat sich heute bei uns
seit heute Morgen bestehend
und auch gelblicher Parfvertrag
auf dem Hauptthiehaut.
Und ist...
Erdmann das?
Ich terus.
Und ja, ich lerne.
Ich lerne.
Ich terus.
Und er gab an,
dass er dunkle Urin,
so wie ich das Tore gehabt habe.
Und er
berichtete über...
Er sagte,
dass er vor vier Wochen
einen Urlaub nach...
Brasilien gemacht.
Und nach dieser Urlaub hatte er
einen Thrombose in linken Beinen gehabt.
Und Fragen nach Schmerzen,
nausea emesis
und Fibar wurden verneint.
Er
fragte nach Schweiß,
Schüttefrost
und Schlafsturgenden wurden aufwenden.
Er klagte über Fatigue-Symptome,
wie Müdigkeit und Asthenie.
Und sie
habe gesagt,
dass er innerhalb 6 Monaten
ca. 10 kg abgenommen habe.
Und wie ich gesagt habe,
keine Nachschweiß und Fibar.
Und als differenzial Diagnose...
Sturveränderung.
Ja, ich habe die Theatoree...
Hellen.
Hellen. Ist das wichtig oder...
Also, wir wissen ja nicht, ob es Theatoree war.
Deswegen würde ich erst mal bei der Beschreibung bleiben, sagen wir es heller Stur.
Ob es Theatoree war, kann sein, aber es kann man manchmal nicht genau sagen.
Ich habe gesagt,
Hellen Stur, ich würde sagen.
Als Risikofaktoren würde ich...
habe gesagt, dass nur Reise nach Brasilien...
Risikofaktoren für was, wenn ich fragen darf?
Reise und...
Risikofaktor für was?
Für welche Erkrankungen?
Hepatitis, ich würde sagen.
Also, denken Sie ja, dann ist der Patient?
Ja, gibt es keine...
Aber 6 Monate habe er 10 kg an der Gewicht verloren.
Ja.
Hepatitis ist eine sehr nähe...
Verdacht, weil...
Ja, das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Ja, das könnte ein differenzial Diagnose sein.
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist Pankreas C.
Okay.
Und beim Pankraskatzenum, normalerweise haben wir quasi den Schmerzen, oder?
Ich glaube schon, ja, Patientin sollte einen Schmerzen gehabt haben.
Aber hier gibt es einen Siklerer.
Und vielleicht gibt es hier Kopfkatzenum von Pankreas.
Und auch in der Gallenwege.
Deswegen diese Brubinhoch.
Ja, und dann ein Pankras-Kopfkatzenum.
Zum Beispiel ein Papillenkatzenum.
Ist ja auch ein paar Pankras-Kopfkatzenum.
Macht typischerweise keine Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, das könnte sein.
Kennen Sie die klinischen Zeichen für ein Papillenkatzenum?
Ja, welches?
Es ist ein Problem, wenn man mit Verdauung zum Beispiel,
eine Übelkeit oder erblichen Quantenum sein könnte.
Es gibt ein klinisches Zeichen mit einem Eigennamen für das,
was der Patient hat.
Wenn Sie diesen Untersuch haben, haben Sie vielleicht auch festgestellt,
dass er ein Ektrus.
Aber Murphy ist auch nicht meine.
Nicht Murphy ist halt anders.
Ich finde mir nichts zu hören.
Ich habe das schon mal von der Covo-Sie Zeichen gehört.
Covo-Sie.
Was ist das?
Ektrus plus Schwellung der Gallenblase.
Das ist ein typisches Zeichen
bei Verdacht auf Papillen,
das ist der Pankeas Kopfkatzenum.
Okay, danke.
Ja, meine,
kann ich diese Verdacht zu sagen,
weil heute ist es ein bisschen kurz,
eine annamnistische Angabe an der ersten
auf ein Pankeas Kopfkatzenum machen.
Richtig, sehe ich auch so.
Als die Fernsehdiagnose kommen Hepatitis
und Gallen,
die Stitis im Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich folgende Untersuchungen durchführen.
Bevor Sie zu Untersuchungen gehen,
Sie hatten ja Risikofaktoren erwähnt.
Welche Risikofaktoren aus der Animese sprechen denn für ein Pankeas Kopfkatzenum?
Ja, als Risikofaktoren.
Welche Faktoren?
Ja, kann ich sagen, als familiäre Belastung,
weil Mutter hat Mama-CA und Vater hat Kolon-CA
und es ist sehr gut zu rauchen.
Es ist ungefähr 50 Packungen für Rauchen.
Ich glaube schon, das ist alles.
Ich folgende Untersuchungen.
Noch etwas?
Aus der Familie und Rauchen?
Gewichtstilus?
Risikofaktoren, das ist ein Symptome,
wie ein Befundene.
Beides kann man nehmen.
Welche Angaben bestätigen oder geben den Anlass
für der Verdachtdiagnose?
Ich verstehe.
Jetzt die helle Stuhl
und dunkle Urwien.
Das haben Sie schon gesagt.
Unterrüstungsweiter ist Glära und Gewichtsverlust.
Und Fatigue-Symptome wie die Öligkeit
und Stenie.
Was ist mit der Thrombose?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Es gibt hier Verbindung mit der Katzinom.
Also das ist ja ein Lattaflugreise entstanden,
kann sein, aber bei Pazia mit Pankeriskatzinom
ist geholfen mit Thrombosen zu rechten.
Das kann auch ein Symptom der bösartigen Erkrankungen
gewesen sein.
Die Thrombose können auch Hinweis für Katzinom sein.
Dann kommen wir zu den
vorgeschlagenen Untersuchungen.
Ich werde körperliche Untersuchungen
machen.
Besonders achte ich auf diese
Zeichnung.
Ich habe ein Schad ins Schreiben geschrieben.
Sehr super.
Besonders achte ich diese Koseviertzeichen.
Und auch McBurnie.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es richtig geschrieben.
Das war ein panzösischer Mediziner.
Dann werde ich ein Labor untersuchen.
Blutblutzucker,
sehr apv.
Wie in einzelnen Parametern.
Ich habe auch eine andere Koseviertzeichen.
Ich habe auch Pankreas,
Abilase,
und Lipase.
Nightwars ist hemmoglobin A1.
Es gibt eine Probleme mit Pankreas.
Es könnte sein,
wenn es etwas steckt.
Es gibt verschiedene
Billorubinen, die diese Messen können.
Was gibt es verschiedene Bilirubien, die Sie messen können im Blut? Was ist da bei dem Patient zu erwarten?
Ja, ich werde es einmal eine Serumbilirubien messen, weil ich wisse diese Kartoffewerte.
Das ist 1,1 mg pro dl. Es könnte mehrmals zum Beispiel fünfmal hoch werden.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Das ist ja auch hoch, weil beim Ektor ist ja auch hoch Bilirubien,
aber es gibt verschiedene Bilirubien, die man messen.
Mein Kollege hat gesagt, dass die Direktbilirubien, da heilt viele Italienische.
Also Direktbilirubien ist erhöht und das Indirekte ist nicht erhöht, ja? Ist richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Und beide erhöht sind, kann sein, aber es ist meistens direkt erhöht, das für die Korinidierter, ja.
Meistens, das beide erhöht beim Paranchimenschaden, ja?
Das beim reinen Verschluss ist eigentlich direkt erhöht immer.
Ja, sie haben nichts.
Und Direktbilirubien erhöhte Direktbilirubien, gleichbleibend oder erhöhte Indirektebilirubien sein.
Und dann werde ich ein Sonografie und Abdomen durchführen, hier die Begrenze der Leber zu beurteilen
und eine Gallenblase und Gallenwege auch zu beurteilen.
Und ich warte auch auf eine vergrößerte Leber.
Warum?
Warum haben Sie eine größerte Leber?
Das ist nicht der Partitist, okay, mein Kopf.
Da sieht man Bankerskatzelnummer aus, Bankerskatzelnummer in dem Frühjahr.
Ich suche nach einer Geschwul oder etwas Tumor oder etwas Raumforderung in diesem Gebiet.
Und wenn ich eine Druck auf Gallenwege bemerke,
werde ich ein RCP durchschoben, um diese Verengung zu lösen.
Jetzt überbrücken, ja?
Also erstmal Katheter, ja?
Ja, erstmal Katheter.
Um zu lösen, dann diese Iterosyptome zu vermindern.
Und dann werde ich genau beurteilen, ist das ein Kopftumor oder etwas
und diese kausalitere Therapie zu fangen, die Chemo am Anfang.
Und dann ist es möglich, ich habe begrenzt, es könnte ein chirurgischer Eingriff.
Ja, beim Bankerskopfkatzen und Papillenkatzelnummer, es ist manchmal gut möglich,
dass sie operativ entfernt werden.
Also eine RCP haben Sie gesagt, genau.
Und dann kann man manchmal, wenn es eine Stenose ist,
dann manchmal mit einer Endotrennage überbrücken, damit sie die Galle abfließen kann.
Dann kann wiederum in den Fall.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt, machen Sie noch ein paar Untersuchungen im Patienten, MRT zum Beispiel, ja?
Ja.
Okay, so eine Umgebungsdiagnostik, gucken, ob in anderen Organe Pathologien bestehen,
ja, Lebermetastas, Lymphknoten usw.
Ja, Sie haben rechts um Staging oder etwas...
Staging, genau.
Ja, wenn wir bestätigen diese Verdachtdiagnose,
können wir fangen mit dem Staging, wie Metastase, Fan Metastase, Lymphknoten, Metastase, Lymphknoten.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Und jetzt haben Sie wangenommen, Ultraschall gesehen, Sie nehmen eine Raumforderung im Bankerskopf
mit Aufstau des Doktoscholletloches und haben RCP gemacht
und dann eine Endotrennage, aber Sie sehen jetzt keinen direkten Tumor in der RCP,
weil es im Paranschüm liegt.
Wie würden Sie jetzt weiterverfahren? Sie haben MRT gemacht, man sieht keine weitere Metastasen,
nur diesen Pankerstumor.
Was würden Sie jetzt weiter machen?
Ich werde jetzt diese chirurgische Eingriff fangen, ich glaube, laparoscopic Eingriff machen,
um diese Kopf so ausscheiden.
Normalerweise besprechen Sie es natürlich immer im interdisziplinären Tumor-Bord,
ob das Patient ist, den man primioperativ klären, also behandeln kann.
Manchmal muss man auch eine Exploration machen, das macht man aber meistens nicht mit einer laparoscopic,
sondern eine offene Exploration oft.
Okay.
Und manchmal ist es so, dass der Befund so ist, dass die chirurgischen sagen,
oh, das ist eine Sache, die man vielleicht doch nicht primioperieren kann.
Und dann müssten Sie aber eine Diagnose stellen, da kann ja auch mal was anderes sein.
Es gibt ja auch chronisch entzündliche Veränderungen im Bankerskopf,
die wie Tumor aussehen können manchmal.
Ja, gibt es ja auch.
Was macht man dann?
Wenn wir diese bestätigen, weil das ist eine sehr froh geschipptende Entzündung der Bankers,
das könnte mit einer Antibiotiktherapie angeln.
Manchmal nicht immer, aber was brauchen Sie denn, wenn Sie den Verdacht haben,
dass die Differenzialtechnik auch etwas anderes ist.
Das Kollege hat auch geschrieben, im Forum gibt es auch mal selten in Bankers,
dann operiert man in der Tat auch nicht.
Oder eine chronische Entzündung, chronische Bauspeiten durch den Kopfentzündung,
die Bankerskatznorm, Sie bauen eine Biopsy.
Oh, okay, ja.
Ja, um eine Diagnose zu stellen, wie machen Sie das bei den Bankers Kopfraumforderung an eine Biopsy?
Kannst du eine Idee?
Ich glaube nicht schon, weil es ist ein bisschen schwer zu Bankers zu erreichen,
aber es könnte sein mit RCP.
Haben Sie gemacht, Sie sehen aber endolumina, Sie haben das Bürstungsprozid,
das sieht man nix, man sieht nur eine Kompression des dubtes Schölle-Doches
im Bankers Kopfraum, aber kein Tumor.
Könnte sein ein Model-Punktion.
Ja, wie macht man das, heutzutage?
Okay.
Wie machen Sie das?
Mit einer Ultraschall.
Können wir diese Festschalen, diese Kopfhandsprangkreas und mit Feinnadeln
bekommen wir eine kleine Gewebe.
Also von außen praktisch punktieren, ja?
Ja, ich meine.
Okay, und gibt es noch eine andere Möglichkeit, außer von außen zu punktieren?
Wenn ich schon so frage.
Kollegen, ja, man kann auch endoscope,
also vielleicht mit endoscope, endosynographische Funktionen,
ja, also machen Sie eine speziale Gastroskop mit endosynographie
und können dann auch von innen, zum Beispiel vom Duo-Denum aus
eine Funktion machen oder vom Magenausgang an, drum bereich, manchmal geht es auch.
Ja, das wären so Möglichkeiten.
Ja, das wären so die Maßnahmen, die Sie ergreifen würden.
Das müssen Sie aufpassen, der Patient ist Privatpatient,
haben Sie ihm etwas gesagt, den Patienten, was er haben könnte?
Hey, das Restanwalter ist immer eine besondere Situation,
Sie müssen Sie genau aufklären, ja, den Patient über jede Möglichkeit
und bei jeder Untersuchung müssen Sie ihn auch über Alternativen aufklären, ja.
Na, echt.
Das ist wichtig, zu wissen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn der Patient CT nicht möchte,
ist bei dem auch ein MRT durchaus vertretbar, ja.
Ja, klar.
Und wenn er sagt, er möchte auch ein MRT von der Lunge haben,
machen Sie das auch?
Nein, es ist nicht möglich, holt es da, weil...
Doch, es ist möglich.
MRT Lunge kann man machen.
Ja, ich werde als Patentenarzt gesprochen, jetzt zum Aufklären.
Ich bin jetzt der Chefart und ich zeige es dir auch,
dass der Patient Fragen haben könnte.
Und dann müssen Sie auch die entsprechenden Antworten haben,
damit der Privatpatient nicht woanders hingeht.
Dann in ein anderes Krankenhaus gehen.
Wenn er merkt, dass es nicht gut sind, geht er in ein anderes Krankenhaus,
dann verlieren wir Geld, ja.
Der Chefart fehlt Geld.
Ich verstehe, ja, können wir diese Lunge...
Wenn er fragt MRT Lunge, sagen wir, kann man machen,
aber es ist für die Beurtein der Lunge nicht so gut wie ein CT,
also gerade bei das Lungengerüstveränderung
oder Medastasen, da kann man eben so sagen, ja.
Gut.
Was haben wir noch für Fragen vom Chefart?
Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Chefart.
Das ist sehr hiebreich für mich.
Es gefällt mir sehr gut, ja.
Ja, und die Antworten sind auch sehr gut,
finde ich bisher ziemlich gut.
Dankeschön.
War eine sehr gute Vorstellung, finde ich, ja.
Es muss nicht immer alles perfekt sein,
aber es ist wichtig, dass man auf alles eine Antwort hat, ja.
Manchmal gibt es auch Sachen, die man nicht weiß,
da muss man sagen, weiß ich nicht, muss ich nachfragen, ja.
Das gehört auch dazu.
Das ist manchmal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Bevor man das etwas Falsches sagt, sagt man,
ich spreche, wenn man zum Beispiel Arztpatientengesprächs hat,
sagt man, ich muss es mit meinem Oberarzt Chefart klären
und würde ihn erst gerne danach ausgeben,
bevor ich hier etwas sage,
was sehr spekulativ ist zum Beispiel, ja.
Nein, ich möchte, dass Sie, ich versuche,
Ihnen mal etwas anderes zu sagen, etwas, etwas...
Was wichtig ist, in dem Zusammenhang ist,
Ihre Kommunikation ist sehr gut.
Sie können auf alles verjagieren antworten.
Das zeigt, dass Sie die Sprache gut beherrschen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Danke.
Wie ich.
Wie Sie, Herr Dr. Gündus, ja.
Sie haben ja auch schon so viel Erfahrung mit FSB-Kurs hier.
Das wird mit der Kopf platzen.
Wenn Sie so viel lernen würden,
dann würde Sie mit der Kopf platzen.
Wenn Sie so viel lernen würden, dann würde Sie...
Ja, für mich gefragt oder Nummer.
Ja, für Sie.
Nein, ich habe schon für FSB gegangen,
aber jetzt momentan nur diese Programme.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, also zusammenfassen, würde ich sagen,
war ein sehr gutes Gespräch mit Patient und Chefarztvorstellung.
Klar, Chefarzt muss halt immer ein paar kritische Fragen stellen.
Das gehört dazu.
War aber alles ziemlich gut.
Ja, klar.
Haben wir Kommentare aus dem Chat?
Ich gucke gerade mal nach.
Ich habe nicht gesehen.
Okay, schon dann geht es.
Lymphoma, Biopsy, RCB von Margen war toll.
Sehe ich auch so.
Sehe ich eine Differenzialdiagnose,
wobei das eher mit Schmerzen einhergehen kann.
Also gerade wenn Sie eine prallerlastische Gallenblase haben
und Ictorus, ja, was kann auch noch sein?
Verstlust, Ictorus kann manchmal durch konkremente Steine sein.
Ja, gar nicht.
Aber dann hätte der Patient meistens Schmerzen,
muss man dazu sagen.
Das wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose, aber wegen Schmerzen.
Die andere Differenzialdiagnose war Hepatitis.
Das haben Sie richtig gesagt.
Und sonst, glaube ich, war das sehr gut.
Die Patienten, die verwenden Trombos,
wegen Pankraschars noch möglich?
Ja, also so oft.
Wir haben einige Patienten,
bei denen die Diagnose Pankraschars über Trombosen gestellt wird.
Die kommen zum Arzt wegen Trombose.
Und dann macht man untersucht,
wenn sie keine Risikofaktoren haben,
die es in der Urkreise gab.
Manchmal kann man sagen, es ist ein Grund genug, es reicht aus.
Aber wenn Sie einen guten Arzt haben, der sagt,
kann auch etwas anderes sein, der guckt nach.
Und dann kann man manchmal auch andere Ursachen erkennen.
Und Pankraschars-Nurmen ist das Katzenurmen,
was am häufigsten über Begleit-Trombosen diagnostiziert wird.
Also als Paraneoplastik-Trombose
durch Veränderung der Gerinnungssystems des Patienten,
ist häufig beim Pankraschars-Nurmen Trombosen.
Häufig als bei anderen Tumorerkrankungen kann man sagen.
Genau.
Gut.